Abstergo umbrellas - welcome to the last
episode my dresses Judas
King douchebag is that what you told him
your name was
why didn't you tell them you're real you
don't remember do you how we tried to
find you look belongs with the fighters
of Sauron give it back fighters of zaron
boys what's going on here is much more
complex than that this isn't the first
time a UFO has crashed to earth you see
in 1947 a UFO crashed in Roswell New
Mexico Oh God top rather spare us
hang on a second a UFO crashed in
Roswell and a new government agency was
created to investigate the paranormal
our agency can we skip this like hit the
skip button or something oh you don't
want to skip this yeah we do I can't
ever talk about it vampires run amok our
agency is there and we have never lost a
fight that is until four years ago when
we investigated a child a child who had
an unnatural power inside him I had
orders from the President to secure the
child so that we could harness his
powers before our enemies could but he
slipped through our hands the government
was the new kid for his farts that's
dumb
it's farts no his amazing ability to
make friends so quickly on any social
network but more he was five years old
he had 3.2 billion friends on Facebook
alone he had any idea the power that
kind of gift yields in today's world
it's time to come with us
Dovahkiin time to stop resisting and use
your gift for your country is he really
still talking are we so different you
and I dobut keen you have to do what the
government tells you to do just like me
we're all just pawns in their game I'll
admit you are fascinating you have more
power than any child I've ever come
across and yet all you seem to really
care about is this it must be very
important what does the shoe whoever
controls this ticket rosy universe
dumbass yeah stupid
but then I wouldn't have to do what I
was told any more I control the universe
get back back I say all of you I can do
anything anything I want
ha ha ha ha I no longer need you new kid
Michael the universe sake why did I have
to see that damn thing how does it work
show me how it works yeah right
Dovahkiin why should we be on the
opposite sides join me Dovahkiin rule by
my side rule and you can have this all
to yourself forever I can offer you all
let's get me safely out of here you can
rule with this once again you
underestimated the character of the
fighters of Sauron what binds us is more
than that relic and you failed to
recognize the character of our alliance
dad and that friendship is more
important to any of us than even the
stick of truth
where are you going
nah [ __ ] sake Kenny at least one of you
has some sense out but why princess
kitty because princess Kenny was born a
half hawk whose entire village was wiped
out with humans and Mari making painting
you see when humans and elves live
together in the forest of hollow Falls
an elven queen fell in love with the orc
known as dand are the first one to
possess the stick of truth they loved in
secret and had a child a beautiful
little girl a girl who watched as
everyone she loved was killed in cold
blood and that is why she waited and
plotted all this time to take the stick
from you for princess skinny his true
hair to the stick of truth
that's pretty camp just one thing Morgan
Freeman how come every time completed
needs explaining you show up because
every time I show up and explain
something I earn a freckle and that's
makes sense actually ok we need to beat
up Clyde awesome look at this new armor
what the [ __ ] is this hold a robe does
it say anything I'm guessing this is
Judas but [ __ ] do I know
Morningstar David all right well let's
beat up Clyde
welcome where can I interest you in some
polite what's here slide wing why here
okay
stick rigid Kenny you don't want to go
down like this back I'm a strange
feeling we're gonna fart on someone's
balls oh my god Kenny sir so [ __ ]
Sugoi keep someone please translate
[Music]
how we're fighting them okay Oh what
[Music]
damn hey that's pretty good
I went to the Kenny son come on there we
go I know the power of rainbow [ __ ] well
we're gonna have to say I'm sorry Kenny
you probably don't have a
[Music]
oh [ __ ] forgot about his ran army oh no
I know what are we gonna do
O'Shea alright Oh sir by myself okay
what the hell that we're gonna do here I
guess you could just keep attacking oh
good I know ah so close that [ __ ]
oh no oh there oh hello
[Music]
what Oh No Kenny do not on the stick of
turf Katrina what is he gonna do again
if you take back the final backup
you think I have to be there I can't oh
yes more damage now my god
we'll have to be tough again with any
Patti kini you were so Sugoi come on
again again [ __ ] sake
that was the hated oh really
now I understand where there was a shop
come on
okay we're gonna have to circumcise him
again
[Music]
sometimes I'm gonna have to kill Kenny I
think pretty awesome don't with the
doggy vomit my [ __ ] come on
yeah we're gonna have to change teammate
to butters
yeah I think but it's better because he
has more health and he's still this
pretty good damage so all right comes
for you Dragonborn
you'd better pray for a miracle what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] no what the hell is this
[Music]
really yeah I don't know either honestly
I'm really confused
[Music]
okay I have talent with me now that's
awesome
okay Elvin army nice whoo oh [ __ ] yeah
streak your coup princess now no no no
[Music]
but he already drank a shot but no
matter princess kitty still has lots of
trig all right children have a [ __ ] sake
I had a nightmare that she's dead
there but she's had set up the main from
Stone Berry who is also your Nazi what
oh god no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's yeah
they're mine
what is this is a weirdest battle ever
okay no one cares
[Music]
sandé channels okay
[Music]
[Music]
finally how many times I have to kill a
princess Candyman ah alright so we're
back where we were five hours ago
beautiful Nazi unicorn Oh for [ __ ]
sake what is it it's not see now no no
sand or something oh yeah all right
this is didn't happen the first time I
don't understand got a cramp I need a
minute all right is it just you me and I
guess the only hope all right you and me
now juice bag for the fate of humanity
it's pretty epic man it's pretty [ __ ]
epic bro down dog
I'll go down oh you better all right
let's see buff head
[Music]
we soak our candy now look at you how
was awesome gotta use that [ __ ] again oh
I'm surprised he made it okay
I don't think Cartman is gonna be in the
next battle anyway so I think the last
time we kill him is gonna be just me
versus Kenny so let's just finish him up
thank you
thumbs up weirdo come on [ __ ] sake
[Music]
[Laughter]
douchebag you remember I made you swear
an oath to never fight on it with us
I'm now asking you to break that up
right there only chance prison is
buzzing tonight yeah no I made an oath
[Laughter]
what about the gentleman's okay
I'm xenoa Bali which one do I use I
guess I need mana for that one I guess I
can follow miss balls
[Music]
[Music]
we're back to normal
[Music]
it all makes sense it all makes so much
sense we're cured that's right son
the Dragonborn was departed on the
princesses balls [ __ ] gay man oh my
god you guys sure about this there's no
other way no no I drove our friend the
madness nearly killed it
[Music]
so I gotta play down about dinosaur
hunters or pharaohs and mummies let's do
that what do you want play next dude I
can't no I can't play your brothers
ready one two screw you guys I'm going
home I'm a pig what the [ __ ] okay I I
don't think ever seen a game saying so
true to it the original whatever it's
not to me I don't know what to call it
but I was just awesome I don't know what
the say man that was just a really
really funny and awesome game to play I
really enjoyed all of it like it was
just so much fun
and I love how games are coming out more
and that they're not being too [ __ ]
serious about themselves there are
actually games with with jokes in them
and it just fits so perfectly with
southpark they they just did such a good
job making me feel part of the show and
I would love to see more games like this
coming out like a CSUN thing I don't
know how they probably took them a lot
of time to develop this but still it's
really cool really cool like I said we
are gonna play old side Chris or
whatever I think that'll be a lot of fun
you know the main story didn't really
it's not like we followed that much of a
story to begin with I think it'll be
cool to do some side quests you know we
have manbearpig and all that stuff I
hear there's a there's quite a few hours
you can sink into it so this is
definitely not the end I'll keep playing
tomorrow I just want to say either way
now thank you both so much for watching
this series I had a blast it's it's it's
amazing that I can do this for you bros
and just play games and especially games
that I really love
as
the best thing ever I swear to God so
thank you both so much for watching for
making this possible thanks to everyone
who made this game thanks to I don't
[ __ ] know but yeah that's it for me
for now stay awesome best